>>> BABE?
BABE.
CAN YOU JUST LIKE GIVE ME LIKE A
MINUTE?
>> JULIA.
>> DAD.
>> LET'S GIVE MOMMY AND GRANNY A
MINUTE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE.
>> THERE YOU GO.
>> MOM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DID IT.
>> DID WHAT, HONEY?
>> RAISED ME WITHOUT GOING
INSANE.
I MEAN, LOOK AT ME.
I'M A MESS.
BUT YOU.
YOU WERE JUST LIKE A PERFECT
MOTHER.
>> NO, I WASN'T.
>> YES, YOU WERE.
YOU WERE ALWAYS SO CALM AND
SWEET WITH ME.
>> THAT'S BECAUSE EVERY MOMENT
WAS A JOY.
>> [ BLEEP ].
SLEEP!
>> I DON'T EVEN REMEMBER YOU
EVER YELLING AT ME.
>> HOW COULD I YELL AT THIS
FACE?
>> OH, MY GOD, LOOK WHAT YOU DID
TO THE TV!
DID YOU JUST PUT PAINT ALL OVER
THE [ BLEEP ] TV?
>> I JUST NEED A BREAK
SOMETIMES.
LIKE I'M COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED.
DID YOU EVER FEEL LIKE THAT?
>> IF I DID, I DON'T REMEMBER.
♪ HAPPY BIRTH ♪
>> I CAN BARELY MANAGE TO TAKE A
SHOWER EVERY OTHER DAY.
BUT YOU WERE ALWAYS SO PUT
TOGETHER.
>> ENJOYING THE SHOW, CHERYL?
>> HELL, NO.
>> YOU WERE PERFECT.
I MEAN, EVEN WHEN I WAS A
TEENAGER AND YOU WERE SUPPOSED
TO HATE YOUR MOM, YOU WERE
GREAT.
YOU NEVER JUDGED ME.
YOU NEVER PRIED.
>> WELL, IT WAS NONE OF MY
BUSINESS.
>> COMPARED TO YOU, I FEEL LIKE
I'M NOT GOOD AT THIS.
>> YOU ARE EVERY BIT THE MOTHER
I WAS AND THEN SOME.
MAYBE YOU FEEL LIKE THIS INSIDE,
BUT OUTSIDE, YOU COME ACROSS AS
SO RELAXED.
>> WELL, I TRY NOT TO GET WORKED
UP ABOUT THE LITTLE STUFF.
>> WHY DIDN'T YOU PACK THE
GODDAMN GIRAFFE?
>> YOU SAID, "PACK A TOY!"
>> I MEANT A GIRAFFE!
>> YOU SAID --
>> SHH.
>> HEY, BABY.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE YOU AND NICK
STILL FIND TIME TO, YOU KNOW.
>> MOM.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT IN THE
BEDROOM WE ARE STILL VERY MUCH A
MARRIED COUPLE.
>> SORRY.
>> YOU ARE DOING AN AMAZING JOB.
JUST REMEMBER TO CHERISH EVERY
MOMENT.
BECAUSE EACH DAY WITH YOUR CHILD
IS SPECIAL.
>> NICK, CAN YOU COME HELP ME?
SHE BLEW OUT HER DIAPER.
>> WHAT?
>> SHE HAS [ BLEEP ] ALL THE WAY
UP HER BACK.
>> OH, THAT'S UP TO HER NECK.
>> AND EACH DAY YOU'LL
EXPERIENCE SOMETHING NEW AND
WONDERFUL.
>> DR. KLEIN, MY DAUGHTER ATE
TWO CRAYONS.
>> NO, FIVE.
>> SORRY, FIVE CRAYONS.
DO WE NEED TO BRING HER IN?
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT I NEEDED
TO HEAR.
SEE?
YOU ARE A PERFECT MOTHER.
>> SO ARE YOU, HONEY.
YOU HAVE POOP IN YOUR HAIR.
>> OH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]